el presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán
ha confirmado hoy que de momento turquía
sigue vetando la entrada de finlandia
suecia la otan y ha explicado los
motivos por los cuales turquía esta
acción hasta la fecha está dicho el
presente turco erdogán que cualquier
ampliación de la otan tiene que contar
con el respeto turco y su aprobación y
que esto no ocurrirá si no se tienen en
cuenta las demandas que aplica turquía
que son entre otras cosas que suecia
finlandia pongan más mano dura en contra
del partido de los trabajadores de
kurdistán en el pkk y deporten a sus
miembros que supuestos miembros que
están en su país y levanten el veto de
armas que apuesta contra turquía después
de que en 2019 turquía ataca sea estas
milicias en el norte se ha explicado
erdogán que una organización de
seguridad como la otan si entras en
finlandia y suecia que se convertirían
en una organización más insegura en
referencia a lo que dice él es el
supuesto apoyo de estos dos países al
partido los trabajadores de kurdistán
una organización una guerrilla que lleva
en guerra contra el estado turco desde
la década de los 80 y en una guerra en
la cual han muerto cerca de 40 mil
45.000 personas tanto a manos del
gobierno y del ejército turco como de la
propia guerrilla del pkk los motivos por
los que ha tomado esta posición
intransigente que está generando una
crisis dentro del seno de la otan son
varios pero son unos expertos sobre todo
se debe a dos el primero es sacar
concesiones de los aliados de turquía de
la otan y el segundo es darle una imagen
de hombre fuerte y progreso al presente
turco recep tayyp erdogán un algo que
casa muy bien con lo que le gusta al
electorado turco y que es algo que es
muy necesario ahora mismo para erdogán
que vive en unas épocas de popularidad
muy bajas por culpa de una crisis
económica en turquía que es galopante